what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 3 of the BCI tutorials to begin we
have now a github as so lots of people
were asking for code and stuff like that
I put that up as well as training data
as well as models and their validation
and all that so a little bit more on
that towards the end but just know it's
up there now so anybody can follow along
if you have a headset you can use the
code that I'm using to create training
data test that training data analyze and
validate that training did all that you
also can grab from our best models and
see how they work for you one question I
do have is is this anecdotal so to speak
because is this are the models and I'm
training really only gonna work for me I
have no idea no clue so anyway love to
know the answer and if you don't have a
headset you can still do things like
train models also at some point it could
be beneficial for example anybody can
download the open BCI GUI and then you
also can actually play back from files
so it's possible I could even create
some playback files and put those up and
explain what the goal you know what what
I'm thinking in the playback file and
then you could you run that playback
file and then you could you can
basically you know synthesize or
simulate having the headset without
needing to spend you know a thousand or
two thousand dollars or something like
that and also you can generate from
synthetic data I don't really think we
have a use for that at the moment but
anyway lots of stuff that we can go from
here and allow people to follow along
and actually try their own stuff and
also you can try to train your own
models and beat our our current results
so okay cool so from the last video till
now I believe kind of where I left off
was I definitely had a model that was
better than random so and then I think
it was maybe a little unclear to some
people
there's three possible actions in the
validation data left right or none so
random would be
three percent so if you're getting on
average about 40-plus percent accuracy
that is better than random you have an
edge and given enough frames you will go
the direction you intended to go okay so
now things have improved considerably
and I'll be showing some of that and
some of the issues that we've run into
along the way as well as some of the
things that are we have to think about
moving forward into the future
so with that let me just dive on in so
um let's see I will just open up kind of
soso mostly these versions are kind of
just me running through the code and
like trying different things so the
version one through three I think yeah
this was like raw signals I tried
networking on v1 but it didn't work
because of the 16 and 125 channel thing
I talked about before but eventually I
figured that out
started v4 and then V 5 is all about
fixing over fitment issues which we will
talk about right now so one of the
things that I found was when I would
actually run validation it would be very
inconsistent so first of all when I
would just train a model I would get the
in-sample data to you know 85 to 95
percent accuracy and then even the
out-of-sample data would also be you
know 75 to 85% accurate I was getting
huge accuracy while training a model so
to exemplify that and to explain what
was going on because this is not DC I
only so as I will make clear this is a
lesson I've learned at least two times
in the past and and it just keeps
smacking me in the face so hopefully I
can share with you guys and maybe you
guys will remember better than me about
this issue so so let's see where is a
model train so proper validation I'm not
even sure what the difference of these
two are let me pull this up because this
one might be
[Music]
I'm not even sure like one of them this
might even be prior to the validation
directory that's my guess training data
data nas one still has it unfortunately
I don't even have the original script
because I got rid of it but basically
what I was originally doing was I was
going into the dated err loading in left
none and right data and then I'd create
the samples and and just to be clear
what each of these directories contains
is a numpy file where the name is just
the timestamp it was created so here is
a bunch of numpy arrays that are 250
samples long basically there are 250
samples of individual 16-channel
fft graphs or fast Fourier transform
graphs so because I pull from PI LSL at
a static rate of 25 iterations per
second each one each of these files is
10 seconds of me thinking this direction
so the first thing I did was load up all
this data store it into like a list of
fast Fourier transform and the actual
target which was converted to a one hot
vector so left 1 0 0 right 0 0 1
none 0 1 0 ok so I made a big list of
those basically and then the first thing
I did to create out-of-sample data was
separated entirely by saying ok what I
want to do is first create that big list
shuffle that list and then take the last
10% of that list
that's your validation data and then
obviously don't train on that data well
that's fine for like typical
classification tasks where you've got
these truly separate samples the problem
is often for sequential data so the
first place I've I learned this was on
Finance data from I'm doing 25
iterations per second so it's 25
iterations of 16-channel fast Fourier
transform data so from that twenty fifth
of a second to the next twenty fifth of
a second that fast Fourier transform
is very similar it will change probably
not much and I know it doesn't change
much because we over fit so the first
thing that I decided to do to overcome
this was actually okay so instead of
taking each individual you know taking
random samples theoretically from each
file because this would this basically
means the add of sample data it's almost
certain that the random samples in the
add of sample data almost identically
will match samples in the in sample so
this is going to just for sure cause
over fitment and it did really well so
so then my thought was okay what I'll do
then is because each of these are a
separate 10-second interval and it's not
even a sequential so it runs for 10
seconds it breaks I have to rerun the
program things change my posture changes
all kinds of things are changing between
each file so I thought okay so then to
make the set of the first true
validation the one that I put up on
github first I took just random files I
would just click this one then this one
and this one and this one and I just
moved them to a validation directory and
the result there now I can actually
start showing you things cuz actually
retained the code the result there is
the following so let's say let me go
ahead and we'll just run this and the
first thing I'll do is so analysis dot
pi basically I did I kind of measured
accuracy in two ways so one of those
ways was to do validate so let me just
pull up both of these so one way is to
actually validate the model and the way
I was doing that is okay specify the
model name and then what I want to do is
actually go and access the validation
directory and then run through make the
predictions return that information
possibly make the confusion matrix which
is what you're going to see in a moment
so that was one way so one way of
validating the model was to do exactly
what I did as I trained the model use
the validation data which I just
explained was me pulling those
second files so if we do that hmm we'll
just do that uh let's make sure let's
make sure that's the same model yeah
that's probably important huh so which
model do we use here 20 at 63 23 let's
just make sure okay they are the same oh
cool so so first let's do the validate
PI so we'll say Python 3 711 cool this
might take a moment I can't oh well we
have that we batch through it so it
should go pretty quick
maybe yep
there is cool so here we have the
confusion matrix for that model which is
stellar
I mean basically 60% accuracy at the
worst right so so this is the action
thought and then this is the predicted
action so in this case I'm thinking left
and 58 percent of the time it correctly
predicts left and then 9 percent of the
time it thinks that's maybe a nun action
and then the other 33 percent of the
time it thinks uh right so one thing
that I do know for sure is this the the
the model is actually pretty good at
figuring out if you're not thinking left
or right but then when you are thinking
left or right it's going to miss
categorize most often the other
direction right so so then you know when
I'm thinking nothing it's pretty good
balance between incorrectly predicting
right or left but then it was 70%
accurate of knowing ah don't go don't go
that direction or don't go nun or going
on anyway whatever and then right sky
same story 60 61 percent correct 21 or
27% totally incorrect right so one thing
you have to think about is if you if you
are thinking hey don't move it's very
bad if you do move and then if you are
thinking right it is worse to think let
like if you if you want to go right it
is way worse to go left than it is to
just do nothing right so so the
difference that's why the confusion
matrix is useful because we can actually
see like okay there there are certain
classifications that
worse than others so anyway regardless
that looks really good but then in
practice it didn't look as good so the
other way I validated my models was when
I actually go to train them I have to
pull up another script with clipping ok
clipping I'll explain later
when I actually go to train them and
these are just previous models that I
used in Iowa like if a model seemed to
go pretty good when I actually was using
them I just kind of saved them into
comments what the heck was that oh right
so so this is the script that I showed
in the previous video where I just say
hey please store this data in the left
directory so the the program itself or
the script doesn't do anything else with
this action other than hey I'm just
notifying the program hey save this
under left otherwise it has no idea what
left even means so so yeah so coming
down here at the end of the session like
this is the script that I run while I
wear the headset while I'm basically
kind of testing a model out and creating
more data at the same time so I am
running this model that's taking the the
fast Fourier transform
shooting that through the actual model
itself if I could find it yeah out model
dot predict we print that out if just to
see it and then we go based on the Arg
max and actually start saving
information and moving that box wherever
we predict it and that's that OpenCV
just it just moves the box left or right
so cool so okay so that's all that does
but one of the other things it does is
it opens up this accuracies dot CSV and
it saves the time it saves the intended
action it saves the percentage accuracy
of that action just specifically it
saves the specific model name and then
it saves all these it's a it saves the
actual percentages for each of the
actions and that's how so I can make
also a confusion matrix on this data
which is the most realistic forward test
you could possibly do right it's it's
truly live it's not validation data so
when I do
that I get a little different answer
because that's what 9 does so what have
I done with part 9 yes
so part 9 analysis reads from that
accuracies file not the validation data
so this is the truest out-of-sample we
could possibly have and when we run that
Python 3 7 and then we go 9 and again
this is off of taking the entire files
not just random samplings from the
entire data set on that exact same model
that's the confusion matrix we get which
is a quite a bit different wait I can't
quite fit it on screen
anyway it's quite a bit different than
the other one right so it is still
impressive it's still accurate it's
right more than it is wrong but it's
different and this hat it kind of makes
me wonder like whoa what the heck is
going on here oh also these are in the
confusion matrix unfortunately has
different values here what this one goes
left right none this one goes left none
right but sorry but you get the idea
it's still clearly in the middle numbers
you can see are very very different
the reason I noticed that I was like huh
that's weird this model didn't get none
is wrong and I was like oh no it's
actually it's just different word anyway
we have a problem because what this this
is supposed to be validation out of
sample data
I believe I did a good job at separating
out the validation after I was like oh
yeah that's right sequential data blah
blah blah blah blah you know the data
that is 125th of a second separated from
the in-sample data of course that fits
that's going to overfit right in this
case I was a little more surprised to
find this much of a different like a I
guess we're still and so it's like data
from the same sitting is a problem which
is very interesting and the data is
taken over the course of multiple days
multiple sittings I would take off and
put back on the headset
I was sitting standing eyes open eyes
closed there's a lot of variation to the
data so it is kind of odd but okay so
just my next thought was like okay well
how can I just mimic this live data as
best as possible the only way I could
think is to just separate out an entire
different day's worth of data that's the
best I got
so mmm so then that's exactly what I did
and that leads us into v5 so we leave v4
and we come into version 5 / fitment fix
so now what I will do is I'll do the
exact same thing we're going to run will
run the same kind of test so analysis
again is running off of live recent data
and then I'll have I done and then a is
running off of so one thing I should
pride you for before I cry is get rid of
the older ones so these are both from v5
yes okay so this all again let's confirm
that we're using the same model for a
comparison 63 - 3 - yes and they're both
from github mode yeah
okay so again same model but different
data let us grab not from this this is
in v4 pull over v5 so now I will just
run Python 3 7 9 analysis PI ok and just
for the record this is actually I'm
trying to think actually you know this
is this I think this is the exact same
model that we just pulled because these
are both the github model that is just a
clipping model if I recall right 63 - 3
I'm pretty sure that's the one that we
were just looking at I'm gonna
confirm just to be a hundred percent not
that it really matters mostly we're just
trying to show in sample versus
out-of-sample but I believe those are
the same models yeah yeah so sorry I
have to confirm because I've used so
many models and like every time I add
more data I train a new model and can
like I just continue that process and
it's been really cool to see how over
time it's actually gotten better
like the first models I trained were
terrible it was very frustrating to like
be trying to think left and then the Box
goes right that's that's just it's just
very very frustrating especially when
especially when people are saying
they're won this is not possible and
then but I'm like I'm pretty sure it is
especially like left right it should
that should be totally doable via this
data or so is my belief and so so people
are like ah no way it's gonna work and
I'm like I think it will but then to
find out if it works I'm sitting here
with a silly thing on my head staring at
a screen for hours trying to move a box
with my thoughts you start to question
yourself so I'm glad that I'm seeing
some results we'll talk about why they
could still be problematic moving
forward but yackety-yak let me I already
forgot which one we ran here so I'm just
gonna rerun it okay so we running
analysis on v5 now let me run Python
three 7-eleven validate model so this
one will actually go through the
validation set with the model making
predictions as opposed to this one just
simply reads the results from my live
retraining that for some reason this is
oh oh that's like I was like oh my gosh
it's it's it's killing me because anyway
but of course I'm running it in v4 whew
what a panic
uh why am i it says v5 what am i what's
going on here oh it was the this is what
fooled me it's the more coffee please
okay now back to being sane Python three
7-eleven felony model that was funny Oh
correct myself up mm-hmm okay so
hopefully it'll be close to this we're
nearly identical but we'll see well okay
so this is using the validation data
although this is still not in the right
order I kind of want to fix that real
quick just so it is identical but I
don't really want to make that fix live
but as you can see there are some slight
differences so left is a little
different if we think left the mistake
to go right is slightly different but
basically the same and then none is
actually identical none and none is off
by a little bit but pretty much these
are these are the same right 15:33 52
this one's actually identical anyway
this is what we want to see so I'm very
happy that okay finally I am confident
in our out-of-sample and the way that we
have to do that clearly is to just take
a completely separate day unfortunately
I don't really like that either because
to me I thought it would be a better
out-of-sample to take many days and
maybe that's what I'll have to do is as
the data set grows I'll just take you
know right now I'm only taking one day
because one day is like that's a lot of
my data right so I don't really want to
dedicate whole days to validation data
but that's clearly what I'm gonna have
to do to get a really good general idea
of how accurate are we actually getting
so moving forward I'm just gonna have to
keep creating more data and then
dedicate some days of data specifically
to validation data that way we get a
good spread over time because just one
day is
opinion to anecdotal I really wanted to
get grabbed the random samplings but you
just can't do that apparently so anyway
that was an interesting finding but also
a thing that I've experienced before
especially with Finance data and just
deep learning in general you often will
find yourself cheating even when you
don't intend to so there you go what
this is cool the fact that I have a
model that is at accurately predicting
all of these across the board more than
random in a true live setting finally
that I figured out how to do that
apparently I'm an idiot
that's so cool like that is really cool
like like I said it was very frustrating
and it still is it still sometimes goes
the wrong way but it's pretty cool to
sit there and think left think right and
move the box and then it's hard for me
to create the data this way I'm still
trying to decide how I want to make the
environment but it would be also cool to
like think left and then change
direction right and then left none holds
you know hold still that's kind of the
next succession here is is somehow
create an environment that does that and
I can't decide if I want to put like a
little dot on each side or maybe say
like left right up top just try not to
not to have some sort of artifact that
shows up in the data and again I don't
know what will so move it you know
taking that to the next step is like
let's say you have a dot on the left or
the right of your screen well that could
influence just eye movement in general
which could then inform the machine so
and then the other thing that is
possibly problematic here is EMG data
and so a lot of times so in the previous
video a lot of people were suggesting
why don't you actually press keys well
if you actually press keys you will
you'll be these muscles will be
activating and that shows up and so you
don't you don't want that so that's also
a way that the model could be cheating
right now is as I think left think right
I might be getting these like little
muscle twitches and that might be
showing up to also if I'm moving my eyes
left to right that shows up the eye
movement shows up really good or if I
like you know flex my eyebrows or
something or a constant my teeth or two
that that shows up right so just
muscle-flexing shows up you're getting
more than just a EEG now apparently I
know nothing other than the claim that
we can do it apparently within the GUI
maybe I can't remember there is a way to
filter out or at least detect EMG so one
of the things I'm going to be looking
into moving forward is figuring that out
how do we go about doing that but
obviously that's something we'll have to
figure out so and then I also have to
kind of decide do I care like as long as
I'm not actually moving that body part
right I'm not sure I actually care all
that Mike if I think left and my eye has
some sort of crazy subtle twitch that I
have no idea about
I mean picking that up is still kind of
cool so I just you know I don't know but
but I think the purest thing would be
indeed do it just with brainwaves that
way like the idea is that people could
use this to to control a motorized
scooter or something like that so if
they don't have arms or legs or
something to twitch it's important that
it still would work right like that's it
would still be that that's necessary so
yeah so I'm gonna try to look into that
stuff moving forward and then now that
I'm actually getting somewhere like this
is pretty basic I will I'm gonna explain
this along with the github soon in this
video but I'm getting somewhere now to
the point where I actually am
controlling that square so now I can
start applying this to things besides
just staring at a script lock on my
screen and I I can I can just kind of
change the environment and in a way I
can still continue to collect data so
I'm not sure where I want to apply it
yet but we'll see I've got lots of ideas
so so stay tuned for that hopefully by
part 4 all have something way more
exciting than the silly open CV block
environment so cool so now let's talk
about the github environment
and what we've got going on there so
close close close close so yeah so
basically everything is here the
training script basically simple enough
it just trains a model and again I think
I showed it in the last tutorial but
this is just a basic model just a 64 by
3 and everybody in the back see it but
even just this model is pretty accurate
this will still get you to you know mid
40s for all of the actions but one of
the things that actually isn't even in I
should add it to this because I actually
have it now I think in the training but
I don't see it here so for me I just did
the the three-dimensional confident and
that does pretty well also people were
asking about confident versus recurrent
net and some people just like I don't
know they don't they don't believe me I
don't know I feel like I've been here
long enough that if I say something I'm
probably not biessing but also you could
just go to google right so if you google
1d confident with attention you should
be able to find some research papers on
this but then also if you look at
typically sequential data tasks and just
see what are people actually doing
nowadays you will see that people are
shifting from recurrent Nets to 1d
confidence usually with attention and
they're doing this for two reasons one
it trains much faster and because it
trains much faster you can much more
quickly iterate your model so you can
actually train them off you can get it
done faster so you can figure out where
to go much quicker you can it can run in
practice much quicker but also that
people are doing better so the the
latest thing that I use this with with
used this with was the text-to-speech
that was a deep convolutional
text-to-speech model it was a 1d
continent with attention but that's just
one of the many things that people are
doing with confidence and attention to
just vastly outperform and like every
freaking way possible recurrent Nets
which is pretty cool this
because there's so much more research
and there's so much more attention being
given to convolutional neural networks
and getting those to go fast so very
cool
anyway that's what I'm doing there is
something to be said though like I am
NOT passing sequences to this confident
this is making predictions 25 times a
second on a single frame which is the
16-channel fast Fourier transform that's
it and just as a reminder that looks
this is a single channel here which I'm
not making predictions on this this is
basically what the model sees only in
numerical form it's not a beautiful
pretty graph like this but yeah so this
is what it's making predictions on so it
definitely stands to reason that
possibly using a sequence of data would
be a good idea totally possible I have
not tried it I want to say daniel said
he tried it and he didn't find much
benefit there but one thing Daniel did
do was clip the data so I want to say
Clifton at 3 and then also possibly no I
think that I think the model were using
clips at 10 or something like that
let's go to maybe models and then the
readme so this is the one that I used to
get a pretty decent accuracy and then
this one is the currently the best
performer which clips at 10 so we're
just running a clip over that numpy
array really basic so that's our way of
kind of scaling the data so I'm really
not doing anything else the only
pre-processing is the fast Fourier
transform which is definitely
pre-processing and then now clipping the
data thanks to Daniels idea to do that
but even before clipping it it was
pretty pretty accurate so that the
information is definitely there and
again this is just on one frame so I
think doing the sequence of data would
help and this needs to be updated with
the graphs that you see here so this was
very recent that I was like still
racking my brain on like well why is in
practice this not as good as the
validation data like in practice you
should be identical to the validation
data
so anyway I will update this but because
this is not true this is the best model
but this was on that validation data
which had a little bit of in-sample
leakage I guess I don't know anyway
cool so if anybody wants to take part
you can you don't need the headset to
try to make these models if you think
you've got a better idea
you have to kind of use the fast Fourier
transform because that's what the data
is but I have hosted all of the data and
I've hosted now the v2 of the data which
you can find by scrolling down maybe and
then back here so you go down and then
you can pick up
oh dear this link here it's on that's
just Sean H Kinsley comm I just don't
know really where I want to stuff the
data right now so it's just there for
now um and that's about it I will
continue to update that especially if I
find some better even better way to do
out-of-sample but also as I build more
data and then I get more out-of-sample
days so to speak I'll continue to update
that right now I think it's about 750
megabytes of data per action which is
quite a bit but it'd be nice to do more
and we still have the problem of in
sample over fitment so when you go to
train a model you're in sample accuracy
is gonna be like 85% to 95% but your
out-of-sample is gonna be like 50 at
best you know so the solution there is
unfortunate and that is that's happening
because from sequence to seer from a
fast Fourier transform to fast Fourier
transform they're very similar so the
model learns very quickly because it's
the data is so similar to previous data
that it's seen even intra intra epoch so
the solution there is to maybe before
you pass the data to the neural network
don't use every sample use every five
samples or every ten samples right but
of course this this you know mutilates
the training data that we have to be a
you know one fifth of the size or one
tenth of the size but once I have enough
data maybe that won't matter so I think
that's the solution to fixing the
out-of-sample the other one could be
possibly training on sequences but again
from frame to frame
we're going to still have the same issue
so surprise the solution is much more
data so that we can throw away a bunch
of samples okay I think that answers
probably everything that gets us up to
where we are but also yay github um let
me see here is this one did I fixed this
one no this one's still bad I need to
update both of these now that I've I
didn't want to update the charts until I
had uploaded the new dataset because
because then people would create them so
if you if you want to try this you can
train a model using the train dot PI
again it's just a really simple example
of a model you can do whatever you want
all right and then once you've trained
your model go ahead and run the analysis
stop PI and that will create the
confusion matrix and the one that we're
looking at right now is just percentage
accuracy but I've got a couple other
ones that you can graph if you so choose
and if you got something that's better
cool share it with us I'll check it out
and I'll definitely attribute you if you
come up with something really good so
there's that and finally if you do I
know such some of you might get the wild
idea to train a model on the validation
data so if that's you I will be having
to validation sets and I will confirm
models on both of those sets so don't do
that please don't waste my time
so anyway hmm I think that's everything
questions comments concerns suggestions
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you still think it's impossible to do
it let me know it's still possible maybe
maybe it's all the MG I mean maybe
that's what's happening maybe it's only
making predictions on EMG who knows so
we'll see hopefully I can figure out how
to filter that out I'm told like it's
possible hopefully I don't have to make
all new data by doing that but that's
also possible but I'd also possibly like
to save the raw data I haven't been
saving all of the raw data and I think
probably my next step will be save all
the raw data because then if we save all
the raw data we could also create
synthetic files that could then be
passed through and all that so and then
again people could do things without the
headset but then also people who think
fast Fourier transform is stupid could
to apply whatever the heck they wanted
so anyway I will do my best to continue
to provide everyone with as much data
and stuff as possible so they can take
part without necessarily needing buy the
headset but the headset is pretty cool
that's it for now
and finally shouts out to reason channel
members a brand new Ferran Stanley harsh
of Ardun ready and Nagisa Raj Viktor do
a and Bill Fujimoto thank you guys very
much for your support without you guys
we would not be moving things with our
minds okay that's all till next time